I read something where you said it's
boring to blindly follow trends and
you'd like to make your own style and
kind of just be your own person and I
see you sitting in this absolutely
beautiful dress I wish the people could
see the print it's a cobra print or
there's there's different - tell us
about that amazing dress I know it ties
into a film that you're a part of yeah I
want to talk about the dress first okay
because if people could see this
beautiful dress and your shoes and the
whole outfit together
they'd be amazed I don't know if you can
stand up for a moment oh I would
absolutely be doing my - it's flowing
it's very feminine and it has an
incredible pattern like a Cobra and it's
just very bold and yes you're wearing it
tonight
yeah into a premiere yes guys very very
proud you've asked this question this
dress is made by a very beautiful
designer friend of mine her brand is
called sahiba Paradis and she is based
in Arizona in California she's an
international designer a very wonderful
friend of mine a dear friend of mine and
I respect her tremendous creativity
brilliance and professionalism as well
she is Indian by origin but her her
whole designer brand and her company is
all international so she works with
these amazing self she this is her
brainstorming heard her designs entirely
and she creates patterns which are
inspired by nature and she says in her
wide travels she travels the world and
whenever she travels she says anything
that catches her eye in the beauty of
nature in the magic of nature and
architecture and environment and
everything she somehow beautifully
incorporates those colors bold bright
colors into her patterns and and she has
this unique way of engineering the print
into the pattern you know so if you
actually notice her dresses there's no
in completeness anywhere you'll see the
prints it's almost as if each it's not
almost as if she actually each creates
each dress as a piece in itself right I
saw the web site by the way it's
absolutely gorgeous what's the URL her
her website is www.pevs.com oh okay and
she has worldwide sales online works
with all these I got I call it that I
I when I wear these dresses I feel this
fusion of freedom flow and fire oh wow I
told her that and she I do feel it I
mean um I was a showstopper recently for
her at Tucson Fashion Week and she
provided this amazing red flaming red
gown for me and I came on stage and I'm
I'm not boasting but the entire audience
just broke out in applause oh and for a
second I stood did I do something wrong
and then I realized that it was the the
magnificence of the dress you know
gorgeous yeah it it has and it's very
comfortable so so yeah I mean she you
can look it up online
anybody can shop online she has retail
stores across I'm sure all that
information is also on her website and
she's growing very internationally as
well she's dressing celebrities in
Hollywood as well and everywhere so it's
awesome I looked at the website and each
outfit or like shirt or or even little
shorts was its own like sort of
masterpiece I mean they're very feminine
you're very flowy yeah and I like that
and the prints were very unique yeah
yeah it was very exotic exactly so I can
see how you would want to wear it to the
premiere tonight now you're in LA yes
for the premiere and the dresses are
they in the movie or you're just wearing
them for the premiere tonight the well
I'm definitely definitely wearing it for
the premiere tonight the one of the
biggest premieres if I may say the
The Hunger Games Mockingjay part 2 is
tonight and we are very excited I'm
gonna be presenting Shahid is dressed
there and nice very excited and no of
course not I wear it in my movies in my
most recent upcoming movie which I'm
very very excited to talk about it's
called Sully Jessica Daaga I'll explain
what that means okay
tagline is be fluid as water Shahid has
provided three amazing dresses for me
which I have worn in my film as well so
yeah and the dresses are very fluid
everything's very feminine and flowy yet
from what I saw yeah that's that's a
good correlation
you